I love a reading I love all the things  but um actually in my family like I come  from a long line of spiritually  I don't know enlightened people like my  mother has what we always called a  really strong intuition and she could  always kind of sniff things out and even  when we were younger she always knew  what was going on in our lives before we  said anything and my grandmother as well  and my brother is actually properly able  to read and he will know things that I  never even told him which is really  wonderful Wow so I don't kind of not if  you want to keep a secret I'm very much  so held accountable in my family no  pulling the wool over your just a lie no  it's not a bad actor when it comes to  you I will not stop talking until you  subscribe to my YouTube channel that's  right and I could talk a lot seriously  not gonna stop yep still here not going  anywhere I see you don't walk away from  this